we're gonna be talking about importing
data into our and we'd add these are the
topics that I want to cover I want to
start with a brief overview of why
dating partner data is important and
importing it into our and then we're
gonna you know take a look into
different types of data that are
interesting to import we're going to
start with tabular data this is pretty
much the file that you would be used to
as importing a CSV you know takes flat
flat text files Excel files SAS SPSS
we're gonna take a look at your article
data which you know it's pretty common
on the web with things like HTML JSON
XML we'll afterwards we're going to jump
to relational data as in relational
databases and finally I want to give a
teaser on how to import data from these
tributed systems you know the more the
more more common term here is Big Data
so we're gonna do a quick demo for each
of these categories and afterwards we're
going to have a session of questions
alright well let's get started with the
overview and this is this is a diagram
that shows how the typical data science
project looks like it came from there
for data science book which is currently
on presale I believe but all the content
is available online and you know what
this diagram tells us is basically you
know the way that I want to see it is
that data importing is pretty important
you really can't have data science if
you don't have data and this is your
very first step before you actually
clean up the data and start
understanding it and you know before you
before you communicate so definitely
relevant and also the caveat is that
there are so many sources that we can
use to import data from that this
webinar is only you know touch the
surface of a lot of different concepts
that we can use to import data there's
going to be more webinars that you can
attend and more resources that we can
phone you to in order to import data
into into our but we're going to cover
the main ones so with that let's start
with importing tabular data and this
might be obvious to a lot of you but
it's good to take a step back and just
think about what is tabular data a lot
of times we think that we
of tabular data but we might not and the
structure is very simple we have a set
of variables right each variable is
represented in a column and each row
represents an observation obviously each
cell contains values and we want these
values per column to be homogeneous
right we want them to have the same type
you know we want to have interiors in
each column if that's an interior column
etc so still it's obvious but it's good
that well you're looking into importing
data you have this notion of how a a
good tabular data source looks like and
if it doesn't look like this you might
be looking at a different type of data
and you might need to use different
different tools so we're going to be
covering a couple of the basic file
types that you might be interested in
importing and for that I'm going to
switch to our studio to run a couple
couple demos so let's go here and we
have we have our studio and we're going
to start by importing a CSV file and the
package that we recommend using for
importing CSVs and general flat files is
read CSV so you can run this comment in
the most simple case you know you only
need a path to your file and then you
know you would be able to view the
contents these files about two megabytes
and you know we can load it all and have
had a sense of how it looks like we have
a couple other couple other options to
import data tabular data for Excel files
recommend a real excel package and again
they function very in a very similar way
so we can run that with the main we
domain with a single parameter right
which is just the path to the file and
get the results and we have a couple
other ones here which come from a
statistical software just executing the
three of them at the same time and you
know we can take a look at what these
data source
contains it's already imported into our
it's good so the very the simple use
cases are very easy to get us started
with there's you know just mostly a path
to the file and each package will do
will try to do it
inference on the columns and data that
is being imported however the feature
that I want to show is a new improvement
that we have in in our studio to make
our life easier while importing these
data sources and the reason why is
decent this is interesting is that not
all the time is as easy as just
importing a file sometimes we want to
change column names you know sometimes
we want to change some of the settings
that each package that provides to us so
here in if you were to click on our
studio under the import data set comment
you're gonna get a new menu now there is
a caveat here this is a pretty new
feature so it's not on their last
release of ours to you you will have to
download the preview version of our
studio now if you're watching this
webinar later on it's it's most likely
gonna be the case that is part of the
latest version of our studio but for now
the easiest thing to do if you're
interested in using this feature is to
download the preview by searching in
your favorite engine our studio preview
and downloading that so you know that
you have this feature if you have a menu
that looks like this and to import a CSV
what you need to do is click on import
CSV and what you would get is text box
with the file name and file path that
you want to use to import data these
file pod supports local sources meaning
that they live on your local computer
but you can also point these to a URL
and import data directly from the web so
let's do this and as you can see here we
have the some of the sources from this
tutorial that you gonna be able to
access and we can pick a CSV file so
when we open the CSV file we're actually
not importing it into our yet we what
we're doing for you is we're giving you
a preview of how the look data look like
looks like so you can see here then you
have 50 entries the file it's actually
longer but we're giving you a
of how this looks like and you have a
lot of options to configure how these
data should be imported so for instance
a lot of data sources don't come with
the first header as names of the columns
so you can toggle that really fast and
you know create an extra 1 3 annum extra
row for these for the headers and also
what is good to see is that we're
generating also a preview of the code
that you would get when you to import
this data so here the parameter that
we're changing is column names so you
can also use this dialog as a great way
to just learn more about radar and the
parameters that need support you can
change if you're if you're if you were
to be importing different delimited file
and you know you have a tab delimited
file or just delimited by white spaces
you can also change those settings here
one of the interesting ones that it's
very easy to do in this dialog is to
choose columns so or change their data
type so for instance at times you would
see that radar is pretty intelligent on
choosing which is the column type that
it's importing so in this case it thinks
that this ID it's an interior which is
it's the case so that's that's a good
data type to use to import this data but
you know like if you look at the date on
this priority date column you'll see
that it we're it's being imported by the
folders character and that might not be
what you want so very easily you can say
change to a date you can specify the
formatting string to parties and accept
the change and as you can see it has
already taken a place and this column is
gonna be imported as a date column you
can also preview the code the same way
we're basically creating as import data
import statement on radar to specify the
column priority date as a date with a
specific file with a specific format
type there a good feature to use and
that I personally use a lot is to say
you can select columns to skip or to
only import so sometimes we have like a
very large CSV file and we're
only interested in three or four columns
so you can use also read reads our
functionality to select only the column
that you want to import so for in the
for this case we're looking at
government data and there's different
application application names each with
a date and this might be all did all the
information that I want so once once you
have a good preview of how the data
looks like you can import that into our
very easily so this how it looks like at
this point this this is a data table
that you can use to further do analysis
on our in a similar way we can do import
data directly from Excel and you want to
select Excel XLS files or XLS X Files
and the functionality is similar but a
bit different one of the most used
features in this dialog while importing
data from Excel is to select the sheet
on the source spreadsheet that you're
interested in so in this case we only
have one but if you were to have
multiple ones you would be able to
select a specific sheet that that is
interesting to you and in a similar way
you can change some of the data types
and skip some of the columns that are
that might not be very interesting for
your data analysis so is this might this
might just be all we want in order to
import this data set and you can just go
ahead and pour it and have the data
frame build for you on our to continue
your analysis let's take a quick look at
one more code path to you know get your
data imported so in this case we'll try
to import sub file and let's see so few
some data set and again some of the
things that you could also do would be
to change their the data frame name so
maybe here we can say you know just data
and you would see that these updates
real time and you get a preview of how
that import is going to look like and
again you just need to click import and
you would get a data frame with that
functionality baked into the read its
add comment so this is pretty much it I
I really encourage everyone just take a
quick look you know and play with the
different parameters it's a great way to
learn about our the community packages
through the ID gonna go back to the
presentation and just quickly cover what
we just demoed
so again this feature is only available
on our studio preview for now so if
you're interested in playing with these
you need to download our studio preview
and the main entry point is to the
environment tab under import dataset you
can select different source sources and
then you would get this dialog to do a
preview in place preview of your data
before importing there's definitely
again we're covering just the surface on
Nar on how to import tabular data
there's more resources that bill upon
you too and there's definitely more
upcoming webinars app if you're also
interested in further topics sorry with
that we're taking we're going to take a
look at another class of data which
doesn't fit well with tabular data and
this is called a hierarchical data so
just a quick review of what is
hierarchical data and if you look at
Wikipedia it would say something like
this a data model in which the data is
organized into a tree like structure in
this particular representation that we
have on this slide you can look at it as
an inverted tree right where you know
there's a model and that model starts
with a road which you know has this
label called pavement improvements and
each of the different branches has you
know a different data value
so whenever you see branches as you know
nested branching when a data set it's
probably not tabular data it's probably
hierarchical data I need to use a
different set of tools to import that
data now the interesting thing about
hierarchical data is that it's really
everywhere and that's interesting
the interesting part so one of the
common file types is what we call XML
which stands for extensible markup
language it looks like the top left
block that we have on this slide and you
know in this case we only have one level
it's a simple note from someone to
someone but we could have nested levels
where you know like the structure is
more complicated interestingly there's a
very strong relationship between XML and
HTML and hTML is basically everywhere
right so whenever you look at a webpage
and you look at the sources you're gonna
see that it follows this tree like
structure when the document it's the
finest HTML document and then there's a
head that describes you know things like
the title on the page and also a body
where it describes the actual values and
in a similar way sometimes where you're
importing data are not necessarily from
a web page but worked from a web service
or from a web api the type of data that
you would usually get is called JSON
which is stands for JavaScript notation
we have a sample on the bottom left of
this slide and it can also be nested and
it's very common you know if you were to
import data from Yelp or some of the web
services that are out there you would
get a nested structure that describes
the request that you're performing and
tabular importing this as a tabular data
structure wouldn't wouldn't feed very
well here so let's take a quick look at
the other demo that we have for
importing tabular data this should be on
the here article data dot our file on
your own the resources that we're
providing on this webinar and we're
going to start by importing data data as
JSON right so this one has multiple
levels so once once the data is imported
we're going to
take the first element of the first
branch and then we're going to take the
first element of the next branch on that
that element so I'm gonna run that and
what you can see is that we're getting a
nested list of data and you know you
would use different tools to clean these
further further up you can do something
very similar by importing XML data so in
this case the way that you access each
node from this branch would be with XML
children so once you import your data
let's import it first now it's on this
node and once you want to once once you
want to access specific data source on
this nested structure you would access
it with by going first the first
children in this case and then getting
the children of that particular node now
more interesting use case is what
happens when you know you want import
data from from the web and we talk
Mendon that hTML is another type of
hierarchy called data and so let's look
at a more interesting example here so
here we're looking at a Wikipedia page
list of countries and dependencies by
population and obviously you know this
is alt text but there is a table that
looks very interesting
and in this case Wikipedia doesn't have
like a download you know data you know
feature or anything but this might be
something that you want to import
directly into R and there's there's
gonna be an upcoming webinar and just
how to do you know web scraping but I
want to give you you know like just like
a quick overview of how you would do
this right so you have a URL so you can
copy that URL and you would want use in
this case a different package called
Arvest and you would call in the similar
way that you read XML or JSON you would
say with HTML and what this would do is
would read the entire webpage as HTML so
now it's part is in a hierarchical
format still not very usable at this
point cuz it's basically the whole
webpage
what you could do is you could look at
the very specific element so you can if
you were to look here at the source of
these page you would see that there's a
table element on on this table and you
could address that specific element by
using what is what is called an XPath to
the element so let's run that and that's
going to give you that particular
element and then finally you can use one
function from the Arvest package which
is very useful which is saying well load
this table as an HTML table from an HTML
table so let's execute this statement
and what you can see is that you know it
starts with that China and you know
biggest population in June 22nd which
you know like it's the first row that
you would get on your web on your web
page and again there's gonna be an
upcoming webinar Fergie's this is just
scratching the surface of what you can
do by scraping data from the web but
it's really interesting and certainly
very very helpful all right with that
gonna come back and we're gonna explore
another category on the data sources
that you might want to import into our
let's see so we look at this couple
these examples with XML our vest and
JSON and now we're going to look at
importing importing relational data and
again I wanted to spend a little bit of
time just kind of like understanding
what's difference between here article
data and relational data so in
hierarchical data as we talked about
we're always talking about branching in
relational data what we're talking about
is relationships between data right in
wikipedia you could find a quote that
reads that data is represented in terms
of tuples and group it into relations
and topples is nothing more than either
a set of columns that are related with
each other but then we can also have
relationships between them right so for
instance some of the things that
wouldn't be a
supported in a hierarchical structure
would be for instance when you have a
list of when your company has a list of
customers so that relationship could be
here article but the fact that also
customers could have relationships with
their favorite brands in there that are
companies you know it's it's kind of
like a loop that goes from customers to
companies and from companies to customer
that you would model without what a
relational looking data structure so all
right so this is how it looks like and
the best representation of these is a
database right so I'm sure a lot of you
would be familiar with databases and the
interesting thing to mention here is
that there's obviously a lot of database
software out there the table on the
right shows some of you know the
different software providers of database
software and there's definitely there's
just definitely a lot of them so what
you really want to do since you know
like this is this can get chaotic pretty
fast if you want to use a package that
can grab that complexity around
connecting to each of the different data
sources with something that it's usually
call a driver which is basically a
translator between what you want to do
with your database and the actual
information in the database and yeah
and for that a great package to work
with these is called DVI and DVI would
allow you to connect to multiple data
sources and we're going to see a couple
examples of these so let me switch to
back to our demo and that would be the
third example on the webinar and one of
the things that you want to do is
obviously first install the dbi package
and then you would have to find which is
the correct back-end and buy back and I
just mean database that you need to
connect to there's definitely different
backends that you could use some of them
are what we call generic and some of
them are specialized so for instance in
this case if you were to connect to Paul
Express you would have
- wrong statement that looks like these
DB connect and then you specify the
pulse first driver the best thing to do
is to use the driver that is specific to
the database that you're connecting to
and mostly mostly because this this is
usually a performance game usually most
of the features are implemented on the
on the specific back-end that you were
connecting to if for some reason you
don't find a driver to your specific
database what you can do is use one of
the generic ones like our ODBC JDBC and
those are standard connections to
databases that usually need a little bit
more of configuration that we're not
doing this this tutorial but it will
allow you to connect in a generic way to
each of the databases another example
very very used database software is that
the driver for my sequel and as you can
see you know it's basically the same a
statement that you would execute for
connecting people Gress Postgres you
would use to connect to my sequel and
that's that's the point of this package
the vbi package is trying to abstract
away the complexities of dealing with
multiple backends into a single package
with very few configuration steps so for
our for our example during this webinar
what we're going to do is we're going to
connect to sequel Lite sequel Lite is
also database software that allows it's
very easy to allow you to connect in
local settings like the one I'm using in
fact in this in this case I'm pointing
this database to be stored in the
database dot sequel Lite file that you
could see on the tutorial sorry webinar
resources so here you can see there's a
database sequel I'd file and all you
need to do is connect to it and it's
going to create a database connection to
that particular data set the first step
that you probably want to do while
connected into a database is just to
list the tables and to kind of like
understand what types of tables you have
in this this database
case is a very simple database it has
only one table that I created myself and
then you in order to retrieve data from
from database you would want to say DB
query and execute a query and this is
this is a sequel query there's a lot of
references on the web on how to craft
queries there's also packages that we
recommend using like applier that will
will remove the need to use specific
sequel queries but today we're talking
about importing data so we're not going
to touch on other more advanced ways of
transforming and manipulating data but
once once you have your data locally you
can you can obviously look at the result
set and you can do the same type of
processing that you would do with any
other data frame in the same way that we
imported here our key called data and in
the same way that we imported tabular
ovular data finally one last step but
not not less important is to disconnect
from the database
it just is just a polite thing to do
otherwise the data the data source might
keep resources running and you know it
could be great performance so you know
just single step the code to disconnect
away from the database if you were to
use again you know one of these comments
they wouldn't obviously work because as
well dealing with database is the first
step that you want to do is connect so
again a quick recap we use the d bi
driver and in order to connect to the
particular database of your interest you
want to use a driver there's different
types of drivers much more than these
three that I'm presenting here and then
you would want to manipulate and extract
data using psycho like statements or
higher level packages like the player
that would allow you to do these without
even selecting having to graph your own
sequel statements perfect so let's go to
the last topic here and
the last topic that we want to cover is
importing data from distributed sources
and what does this mean so we talked
about you know we already talked about
tabular we talked about here article and
relational and this is a little bit of a
similar concept but the scope is
different right
so in a lot of cases you know when
dealing with CSV files you can have the
CSV eight files on your local machine
because they just fit into memory and
that's all good and it's usually you
know it's usually okay to just import a
CSV file directly from your local
machine sometimes that the data grows
data gets poured it into relational
model and you can import this data with
those like PPI as we saw in the demo but
there's also cases where the data just
doesn't even fit on or it's not advice
to be feeding to a database relational
model so in this case is we're talking
of what what is also known as big data
where the data just doesn't fit into a
single machine or even a few machines
you know like databases it's not
uncommon to have like you know under
replicated database with three or four
machines but something's data doesn't
even feed them those systems and you
need like several hundreds or several
thousands or even tens of thousands of
nodes by know what I mean what we're
representing on top of these on the top
of this slide
I know it's I mean just computers so
when they know doesn't fit on a few
computers or even a single computer we
need to introduce the concept of
distributed data and basically what it
means is that we need to split the data
into multiple different pieces in order
to be able to deal with it right so if
you have like a really really large file
that doesn't fit on one machine but it's
only fitting like chained machines you
don't have to distribute that file
across like all those different machines
and somehow work with it on our so so
that's that's a bit what I want to talk
about on these last conceptual data
source you have a lot of data it's
distributed data
is just not possible to deal with all
the data in your machine running you
know like a single hard drive with you
know a few processors so how does that
look like so there's there's two
approaches to tackle this problem of
having too much data that doesn't fit
into one machine that you can't really
import into your our session so the
first concept is something and this is a
statistical concept and the idea is that
you know you might not be able to bring
all the Twitter data into your laptop
that's just not feasible because it's
just too much well you can definitely
take a subset of that data so you can
say well you know I know that I can take
all the information from all all they
all these countries but I think I can
take a few rolls from each country and
process that in a sub sub sub sampled
weighed on the local on the local
machine so that's that's one way and
that's that's what we're going to
explore today on the demo on during this
webinar the second option is to say well
I know that the data doesn't fit in this
particular machine so instead of running
my code on with a subset of data in this
current machine what I'm gonna do is
instead we're gonna run my our code in
distributed fashion across all the nodes
and do the processing outside of this
current machine and that definitely
deserves webinar by itself and
definitely there's interesting news
coming on this topic but today I want to
I want to focus on sampling so two
options one is reduce the number of data
that you bring down and the other option
is do processing of data outside of your
current laptop and do it on on each node
so let's look at how it looks to sample
data on for a specific for specific data
source how would we bring data into our
and again like I'm not talking here
about very specific technologies because
there's just so many I've listed some on
the right side of the slide we have a
spark Hadoop Cassandra mesos there's
just a lot of technology so they'll
definitely deserved its own webinar by
itself but I I want at least exposed
exposed ourselves in these during this
webinar to on how how we would tackle
this problem so we're looking at the
sampling approach and what I'm gonna do
in this case and this is you know
unrelated in some way with our since
it's gonna be dependent on each system
that has distributed data but the
approach would look a little bit like
this and you know we don't need to go
into details I just kind of like want to
present how this would look like and the
idea is here what we're using is what is
called we're getting data from spark and
we're using what is called a spark show
and the approach that I want a percent
is it's pretty simple so what what you
would do is you would find where your
data is usually the data is in systems
like Amazon s3 or HDFS in this case for
this demo is just a local it's a local
file and then you would load you would
load that file using the distributed you
know system and that still you know
we're just we're working against you
know not our poor against the
distributed system in this case is spark
then you can do you know you can do a
couple of things like just getting the
number of rows and here the interesting
thing you know we are only looking at
5,000 rows but in a real application a
scenario this could be billions or you
know like even hundreds sort out that
you know it would be like a much more
bigger data set that just is not
feasible to bring down into your own
into your own machine so what we're
gonna do in this case is we're gonna
take a sample of the data and a lot of
distributed systems provide
functionality one way or another one to
you know get you extract a subset of
this data so that's exactly what we're
doing and then in this case what we want
to do is we just want to save the file
locally in sparked this concept is
called collecting the data what we're
going to do in this case is save it and
as you can see a new file appeared here
which is the sample subset of the data
and again we
look at a lot of the details on how to
do this mostly because it's a little bit
out of the scope of how do you would
import data but my bigger point here is
that you know if you were faced with
this problem what you would want to do
is either ask someone or yourself try to
sample down the data for this approach
for the sampling approach so here you
can see that is as a CSV file and we can
import the CSV file using the same tools
that we just learned about today so
let's browse for this file that just got
probably today it's called sampled with
the same name we're going to open it and
as you can see you know we have we have
it's it's the it's the data item that we
would expect but it's sampled to
something that is manageable on on our
specific laptop right so here if I
import this one and I were to say let's
look at the number of rows from this
data set you would see that it only
contains a subset of the data that we
are we imported all right so I guess we
were back to two important CSDs at the
end of this this webinar might be a
little bit ahead of time but the good
news is that we will have more time for
questions then okay so the first one is
this new import database feature only
available in the premium premium version
no the answer is no like actually should
not mentioned is but all this demo was
performed in the open source version of
the product
so the DBA DVI package that I present it
is an existing package you can download
it for crap from cran it's open source
as well so you can just go ahead and
install it take a mix on our they're
virtually mutations for importing SAS or
SPSS over the years architecture of both
files have changed so my answer is here
no to my knowledge but no it's my belief
that you know there shouldn't be any
limitations I don't know how far back we
go into important the file you know like
you know from all the very all the files
that I've tried like they all have work
for me but I'll be happy to follow up
and find for you if there's any
particular restrictions that I'm not
aware of next question does the import
provide means of importing fix with data
no the limiters field start at a given
character etc yes the answer is yes and
I'm assuming that I'm still present in
correct a bill yes you are yeah okay
perfect so yes the answer is yes there's
there's tools for importing fix it with
fix it weeds are columns now we don't
have that particular feature on their
data import at the moment you know it's
only delimited but if you were to look
at the reader read our package you're
gonna the function that you want to take
a look at is read fwf which stands for
fixed width and it comes with a few
different parameters that you would have
to specify to the to the actual import
function and that would accomplish what
you're trying to to do in this case
which is importing data would fix with
so as long as you're using the package
you would be you will be fine look at
another question here what
about reading zip files oh that this is
such such a great question yeah so some
of the us so my my recommended approach
would be to you know extract the zip
files yourself this is just to me it
just makes makes the most sense we
there's actually packages which I don't
remember on top of my mind to extract
the v1 extracted package directly from
from our there is however a couple ways
that some of the packages I believe
radar would actually take a look at
extracting the file itself but it's not
is that something that I would
personally recommend in general you know
you it's not just that you know usually
it's not about just reading the zip file
but the zip file contains multi for for
files etc so I think it would be my
recommendation to rather take a look at
you know like what is inside first use a
different tool either from our or
outside our to extract that zip file and
then import the data that's that's just
my take on it okay another question
let's see when will the new version not
preview of our studio we did import be
released yes
so I guess my answer would be hopefully
soon I don't know bill if you have more
information there but like I don't think
we've released anything particular I'm
really excited to be like it's it's
pretty decent so I guess what I what I
can say about this question is that you
know like then we in our studio we try
to do a very good job on keeping our
preview release versions as stable as
possible so I wouldn't be afraid of
trying the the preview version
definitely you know once in a while we
might react you know to issues that we
that we find in the preview version but
you know I would just encourage you to
use the premium version and I would like
to say that the answer is not no fair
enough but I don't think we have we have
released any particular big hairy ride I
can add to that that if you subscribe to
our blog or watch our Twitter feed
you'll see a whole bunch of
announcements coming out when we release
the stable or the full version right now
so I like that even better
perfect yeah so let's subscribe to the
block that that would be the best way to
to find news about inversions first to
you alright another question what would
be the best way to import Assad's data
setting to are ordered I'm converting it
to CSV reading the scenes we've files
now yeah so I definitely went very fast
on all the concepts here but let's let's
just redo this the SAS case because you
shouldn't need to convert to CSV even
though that's certainly an option you
can use you can use to export a CSV and
then we import it back what we recommend
instead is to use the haven't package so
which is what we what we demo and you
can you can import by reading from SAS
in a similar way you can go directly
today to the dialog and look for a sales
file that is of interest to you without
having to go through the group of you
know exporting a CSV and then converting
back while you're reading in our so here
what we're doing is we have a SAS file
I believe this is the data set from iris
so Mike might look familiar the data set
from those of you who are already doing
analysis in this data set and you know
yeah basically what you would do is you
would go ahead and you know imported
directly in this case we're not we're
not converting to CSV I know I know
desire look look pretty similar but
actually what we're doing here is were
calling direct SAS package with a
particular file and we're just gonna
import it and it's not converting at all
to CSV or reading from CSV just directly
going using the haven't package and
getting it as as as a source so yeah
this is important dataset all right
let's look at a couple other questions
does the our studio preview import
interface work with a new federal format
ah my goodness yes
I mean no but I would love to so yeah
the federal normally just add a great
file format we didn't have a chat
to talk about further today for those of
you that are listening Federer is a new
file format that is helping people
interoperate between Python and R and
it's also designed with fast access in
their in their design so it's a very
fast file format loading and saving data
it's very very fast I think it's just a
great suggestion and currently no
there's no integration with the Faro
format but you can you can install
further the further package and
definitely search search online for our
feather or will there be an eco system
created by our studio involving spark
Sandra HBase with the player likes index
hi good news these some of these
questions are tricky so you should keep
in you should next week we have used our
and we're planning to do you know
announcements around you know like
feature new features interesting things
happening on on our studio so definitely
as bill was mentioning the blog is a
great resource to keep track of these
but currently we don't have any any
particulars that that that were we're
ready to share but yeah I definitely I
mean obviously this would be the data
big data is interesting so you know it's
to have to help the community also
connect to these data sources let's see
is there a way to import cubes into our
and by this my cubes probably I guess
what the question is referring to my
guess is it's talking about business
intelligence cubes just di cubes and
things like that I actually don't know
the answer to this question my guess is
that it there's the answer is yes
because there's you know we have there's
the our community so big and trading so
much that there will be something out
there we can do a quick search you know
depends because it's not there's no file
format for cubes right like cubes are
specific to each vendor right so you
know like analysis services from
Microsoft for instance would have like
we would record different tools to
import data directly well you know like
some other you know source would from
Oracle you know like business
intelligence suite
requires some other similar package but
what I can say is that for this question
is that the same approach that we use
for distributed data you know would
obviously work for cubes where you know
like you extract the data that you're
interested from from the system and then
you import it into our how about another
question how about the meta information
usually present present in other
packages files like labels notes
severance data we'll all be able to deal
with meta information and soon so yes so
as I mentioned what we're importing at
the moment is with the heav'n package is
tabular data so kind of like as this
question is suggesting meta information
you know like would not be part of that
tabular data just because the format it
doesn't match us you know that's nice
that you would want directly to to to
metadata right like there's really no
great way of enhancing a traveler data
format we would metadata I am not aware
of the the specifics of the having
package would provide you with a way of
reading metadata again feel free to
shoot me an email you know for this is
usually the good news is that is usually
the valuable information is not in the
metadata but it would certainly be
interesting to be able to access
meditate as well